foreign
guys this is your vice president for
internet infidels Edward Tunisian as you
all know I have that good scholarly
paper on the origin of evil theistic
heart determinism that people like John
W Loftus and others have been promoting
and uh I have invented their very first
official YouTube Channel free thinker
podcast where I've interviewed great
individuals and today I'm going to be
interviewing some other great
individuals that have already done
interviews with namely the ex-cuban spy
and physicist Bill gatie thanks for
being on and uh Jason Thibodeau who's
one of our board of directors and has an
excellent piece on the periphery of
dilemma available in Internet infidels
modern Library section and uh today
Bill's going to help us talk about some
physics and some problems with the
mathematical establishment so I'll just
let you take it away Bill and he can
tell us whatever you'd like to say
well okay the issue I guess uh that um
we were going to talk about today are
dimensions Dimensions coordinates and
vectors I guess I'll put all three of
them in there and what I want to say
there to start out to kick uh start the
meeting here is that
um mathematics has a different or we can
call it mathematical physics has a
different notion of what a dimension
coordinate and Vector are compared to
what genuine physics okay so we have
mathematical physics against genuine
physics genuine physics says a dimension
is length width and height that's what
it is what's the definition well if you
take a um any Dimension it has two
properties it has orthogonality and it
has Direction these are two qualitative
uh parameters okay it's just uh
Direction and orthogonality none of that
is what is in the definition or the
notion of the attention of mathematical
physics in mathematical physics they say
it's the number of Numbers number of
coordinates that's what a dimension is
and then they continue with the
definition what's the issue the issue is
that the definition that mathematics has
mathematical physics really uh has four
dimensions coordinate and vectors have
nothing to do with Dimensions
coordinates of vectors of physics they
are number lines that's what they've
defined they've defined what a number
line is a number line does not have
Direction a number line does not have
orthogonality perpendicularity with
respect to anything which is the
opposite of what the physics one notion
of the of this word not Dimension is
what the the notion of phys of
mathematical physics has is uh you know
for number line is that it's just has
magnitude which is what the one in
physics does not have the one in physics
is length width and height they're
qualitative all they have is Direction
and orthogonality the one in
mathematical physics is not really a
dimension coordinate or vector it's
really a number nine all it has is
magnitude
if you look at uh if you put up number
two I'll ask uh Jason there to put up
number two we can get a snapshot of what
I just said
yeah sounds good
okay you can see the dimensions of
physics all they have is length width
and height low in the case of
coordinates it's longitude altitude and
latitude and in the case of vectors it's
a death breadth and elevation in the
case of Dimensions we're talking about
um orientation tilt of an object it's uh
it's reference with respect to the rest
of the universe the arrows go outwards
in phys in uh in uh under physics
coordinates it has to do with locations
and the arrows Point inwards towards the
object from some reference point
they're only qualitative they just say
this is the location of this object for
example with respect to the walls of
your house
for example table and in the case of
vectors it deals with motion and it and
again the words are death breath and
elevation on the other hand if you look
at the math I don't know if we can see
the bottom of that I only see
uh yeah if you can raise that a little
bit the one for math
uh just give me a second maybe make it
smaller yeah that'd be it's it's showing
up oddly on my screen so let me try
something different
um
nope that didn't work making it smaller
maybe
um
sorry I'm gonna I'm gonna stop this and
do a slightly different share and that
will probably help
um do desktop
all right so we're not seeing the same
one anymore we want to see number two
there we go okay yeah
that's close enough yeah yeah good what
we what we have here this is the third
one but it's okay it's uh more or less
uh
no it's fine either way that's good yeah
this one anyways it tells us anyways the
same thing in a little more detail you
can see that in mathematics which are
mathematical physics uh really is
mathematics all they're talking about is
magnitude they are not talking about
orthogonality perpendicularity or
Direction which are qualitative Notions
which is what the ones in physics have
and what the one in physics have uh
don't have is magnitude okay so uh the
the ones in math uh have nothing to do
with the ones in physics and vice versa
why is this important well because you
you probably heard in general relativity
that time is deemed to be a dimension in
fact it's supposed to be the fourth
dimension okay and uh what they're
talking about is not a four-dimensional
object such as a tesseract is supposed
or allegedly supposed to be what they're
really talking about is four number
lines they're saying you need these four
numbers like a um you know uh to locate
an object within space time in other
words it's it's like a circular argument
uh uh an event is a point in space time
how do you locate it well you need four
numbers you could uh say it's a
quadruplet right
um that you need these four numbers uh
which they say it's uh longitude
altitude and latitude together with time
to locate an object within space time
that's called an event and the problem
there also is and I think uh maybe I can
tell you which one it is I think it's
four or five the one that says event
I know the next one down I think oh
event there we go yeah yeah okay uh see
uh Stephen Hawking says an event is
something that happens at a particular
Point okay
Etc et cetera Etc well a point is a
location it's a static concept happens
is not a static concept happens is a
verb and so we have a verb happening at
a single point in time at a single
cross-section of time you could say of
of the universal movie so we have a
problem because in order to have time or
motion you need at least two frames of
the universal movie for something to
move there's something to have time and
here they're talking about a point in
time because they designate that point
in other words time was just one time
they can say 45 seconds or 10 45 or
whatever number they put in there it's
just one number and they see it as a
cross section of time of the universe
right of the universal movie when that's
not the case the case is that you need
two points in time two points to
designate time you need at least two
locations to designate motion to
designate time and so they have this
this notion that the fourth dimension is
time when they're not even talking about
Dimensions at least not the ones of
physics not not one that refers to an
object so they can't say well I'm going
to illustrate or I'm going to try to
illustrate or I can't imagine this
four-dimensional object of course you
can't because you're not talking about
an object you're talking about locating
something within space time which is a
totally different concept than saying
try to imagine this object okay so so we
have these differences between
mathematical physics and qualitative
physics genuine physics physics we try
to explain a phenomenon and these people
are not these people don't have an
explanation for the physical for what's
going on in the universe all they have
is descriptions mathematical
descriptions for how things move those
are two separate things and I think
that's where we have a divorce between
genuine physics and mathematical physics
awesome real interesting and uh before I
let Jason comment I don't want to lose
the moment I want to go into another
question that's similarly related
because I think it's interesting and it
might help build a better foundation for
Jason to come up with some more
questions so uh here's my question bill
so 3D objects have length width and
height we see and interact with them
every day but that is all that is 3D
images and dreams only have the illusion
of 3D and even 3D video games are in 2D
but the shapes and depth Illusions make
the game look like 3D there are also no
such things as a 3D Point All Points
have at least a little bit of length and
r2d you know like if I imagine a 2d
point you know it has length and width
no height and um the only thing quote
unquote that is one dimensional would be
if the very tip of a really sharp pencil
which brings us to a good point pun
intended is a 1D is one d a standalone
principle or can it Be Imagined only if
there is length in other words can I
just imagine One D alone
well I think we have to go back all the
way to Euclid to answer this question uh
the set of questions that you asked we
go back to Euclid and he defined a point
as that which has no part okay that's
the translation whether we understand it
the way he did I don't know but
essentially he was saying look you don't
need a dimension to designate a point
and and the question is are we talking
about whether the point itself is a
physical entity that has linked within
height two two Dimensions one Dimensions
or none at all or are we talking about
how to locate a point within something
else which is a separate issue okay so
we're talking about two different things
here and and the the issue here is that
we we haven't changed that definition in
what 2000 uh plus years okay what
happens is we have the point we have the
line which we say is one dimensional but
obviously they're not talking about a
physical object because there is no
object that is one dimensional that you
can even imagine
so the Zero D point that we have today
supposedly right and the 1D line are not
they're not um uh what is it they're not
geometric figures a figure is 2D or 3D
yeah
it's not more than that you cannot have
a four-dimensional figure and you cannot
have a one or or a zero dimensional
figure no such monster because what are
you going to put just length well please
draw it whatever you draw is going to
have these two Dimensions so so we're
going to have a problem between the
architecture the the the structure that
we're talking we're referring to using
the words length width and height on the
one hand and on the other the fact that
you know we're we're talking about how
to locate a point somewhere and for that
you know I I distinguish between the the
uh chord is because now we're talking
about location it's going to be
coordinates I distinguish between uh
longitude latitude and altitude from uh
and I think it's number four there uh
where um you'll see that we have a
sphere and they're not talking anymore
about longitude altitude and uh the
third one latitude altitude and
longitude they're talking about radius
uh Meridian Meridian I'm sorry yeah
radius Meridian in parallel yeah and and
no and the other one was what is it
parallel yeah parallel Meridian and
radius these are number lines these are
number lines the reason they can curve
them is because they're not they're not
really Dimensions because they lack this
orthogonality as soon as you observe
them and so they calculate angles
because that's what they're interested
in and they curved these uh coordinates
and what they're really referring to is
number lines which again have no
Direction they're talking about numbers
okay yeah so we distinguish that from
the ones in physics okay and so would
you say that I think I remember reading
one of your you stupid relevist
um uh web pages on your site and then
you said I believe that the only thing
that is one-dimensional is like the very
tip of a pencil
is that correct or what do you mean well
uh if I said that I must have been
joking no there's really nothing that is
zero or one dimensional uh everything
everything is either two or three
dimensional okay whether it's a drawing
you know whether it's a pixel and a
screen whatever thing you can imagine
you know we're talking about uh
something which is if if you can image
it you're talking about these two or
three dimensions okay that's what I
thought yeah
yeah without a little bit of length and
like uh just to give a comment I
actually talked with Jason Thibodeau
about
um what's his name Carl Sagan and uh the
flatlander example and the problems of
it and like even kind of and Charles
Sagan kind of emits a little bit of
defeat because he's like you know like
these little cards here that represent
the Flatlanders they have a little bit
of height to them but we'll just pretend
that they don't have height but if they
didn't have height how could you have
motion like how could he be he couldn't
be moving anything you know and so it's
like he kind of had like a whole kind of
starting point already you know and then
like you know he said like I can't like
you know there's bad back and forth and
then there's up and down in our universe
but then there's other directions
perpendicular to that I can't show you
what that is and it's like you know well
so I mean that was interesting yeah so
yeah thanks for pointing that out bill
that's kind of like what I was thinking
about like because like you know you
know like when we were talking uh me and
Jason about like hypothetically speaking
if he had 2D Flatlanders and I brought
up the point that if they were to
imagine something and their Universe
couldn't they only imagine things in One
D and like but then like that's
impossible because you can't just
imagine one dimension they have to be a
little bit at least a little bit of
length to give it you know like you know
characters you can imagine it's like the
whole starting premise of like the
Flatlanders being able to exist was just
off so yeah so thanks for clarifying
that bill and then uh so I'll just let
Jason chime in I'm sure he has some
questions and then we'll move on from
there
okay thanks Ed um so one question I have
I guess I have a couple two or three
questions one is
um if Dimension is something that has
directionality and
orthogonal yeah does that mean I
that I mean that kind of just rules out
time as a dimension doesn't it because
because it seems like
I mean we talk about the direction of
time but I take it that's not Direction
in the relevant sense
there is no Direction because whenever
they talk about the so-called you know
use quotations on that whenever they
talk about the direction of time what
what they're really talking about is
forward they say time moves forward but
forward is not a direction because your
forward is a little different direction
than my forward so what do you mean time
flows forward and again they use that
word forward and they think they answer
the question of Direction when in fact
time has no Direction because time is
simply a counting of numbers also that's
all it is all we're doing is adding
numbers on the clock because as a little
hand goes around it all we're doing is
adding numbers time has no direction and
and it's so funny when they do their
space time diagrams you know Mr feinman
and he's got time go he replaces height
essentially with time he says he's
replacing the word space for the other
three dimensions he puts them all
together in this one horizontal Arrow
and so he's got time going perpendicular
to space which makes no sense whatsoever
because uh time has no Direction
so I I have some questions about the
implications of this for our
understanding of modern physics which
I'm sure you're going to get to
um so let me ask a different a question
it's not directly connected to that at
least not right away not immediately and
that is that um one of the issues that
that Ed and I were talking about was
whether there could be there even could
be a dimension that is orthogonal to the
other three spatial Dimensions
um and so I wonder just what you what
you would have to say about that because
I mean it's one issue about whether time
is a dimension but there's a separate
question about whether there are other
spatial Dimensions or at least possibly
other spatial Dimensions than the three
that we've been talking about yeah so
he's talking about whether a 4D
Tesseract could exist like yeah yeah
okay I understand the question this this
is my answer to that I have to give you
an explanation how this universe works
I'm gonna I'm gonna try to explain
gravity to you I'm going to try to
explain magnetism where electricity to
you I have no use for this fourth
dimension at all but uh but let's assume
there is one out there if I cannot
present it to you if I cannot show you
in any way what I'm talking about I'm
just telling you you know there's a
fourth perpendicular dimension which is
perpendicular to length width and height
you know I'm talking about bunnies uh
you know talking about Alice in
Wonderland I'm not even talking about
that I'm talking about irrationality
because I cannot I cannot even show you
what I'm talking about I mean if you ask
me about God I can say look uh here's
God and I bring an image of uh God the
one that
um you know the painters in the 16th
century painted on you know their uh all
these artists that painted God in
different ways I'll bring that and say
look this is God okay that's my God and
that's the one I show you and you say
okay I know what you mean by God by the
word God I cannot do this with a fourth
dimension I cannot bring you the fourth
dimension said look this is what I mean
by the fourth dimension what am I going
to show you
anything that's more dimensional so so I
could and this is what I mean and this
is what Sagan said in that video is yeah
I can't show you it but I can Define it
I can say that it is a dimension that is
at 90 degrees to the other three except
except except yeah but he's got a
problem Mr Sagan here because what he's
doing he's he's talking about structure
and structure we do not Define sub the
structure we point to in other words an
object like you say what's a table or
you want to tell the Klingon you want to
teach them your language so you say look
the word table what is a table well
table is that and you point to it and
say okay what's a chair that's a chair
that's a rock that's a tree you point
and name that's the way you present a
structure but Carl Sagan can't come in
here and say look I can't point to it
but let me Define it for you let me tell
you what a table is no no you first
point to a structure then you can Define
and say well it's got four legs a
platform whatever but you can first you
got to point to the uh to object you do
not Define objects we Define Concepts
not objects and see so he's he's getting
mixed up between his Concepts and his
objects objects we point to Concepts we
Define
um okay so
um my other questions do have to do with
more related to physics
um so I don't know how much maybe if you
say you're going to get to this in a
minute then that's fine but so one one
question I have is
what about what about singularities
um it seems like your view would be they
don't exist they're not real yeah well
Singularity is a mathematical concept
and the one of the problems is that they
have invented a word that is an
irrational term and that's a word
infinitesimal okay it's an irrational
term but mathematicians love it because
what they use is this as X approaches
zero the limit as X approaches zero and
so the question is that infinitesimal is
both zero and approaching zero in other
words infinitesimal means the state you
being at the station and you getting
closer and closer to the station okay
so so they use the word infinitesimal to
give you the notion the feeling that
something is becoming so small that
we're not going to talk about it anymore
you know you know what I mean it's
getting small so is the singularity
infinitesimal or is it zero is it zero
volume or is it approaching a point
where it's becoming a zero volume and
and uh I've got the if you look at
numbers I think it's six or six I think
it is uh Hawking
yeah here uh Chandra sucker calculated
that a black hole which at its Center
has a singularity is Zero Dimensional
okay he he calculated he got the
equation he was rejected by his boss at
the time which was Arthur Eddington and
uh Einstein himself here you can see
um hockey's own words Einstein himself
wrote a paper in which he claimed that
stars would not shrink to zero size zero
size that means they all understood what
chandraseka was saying he was saying
that the the so-called black hole
becomes a singularity a zero nothing all
that matter that the star had uh was uh
compressed into zero volume with
infinite uh density so so we got a
problem because these people are saying
look there's nothing there we have an
infinitesimal Singularity meaning that
it's getting closer and closer to zero
but not quite zero volume and so they
they play around with this they give you
the impression that there's a DOT there
called a singularity when there is no
dot The Singularity is Zero Dimensional
in other words there's nothing there
that's the definition of nothing because
on top of that we crushed matter out of
existence you know by doing so but this
the so-called black hole it's pressure
so great that it crushed all matter out
of existence mass is a measure of the
quantity of matter there is no matter in
a black hole because it was all
completely crushed out of existence we
have a Zero Dimensional Singularity that
has nothing in it because all matter has
been crushed out of exist and has no
mass that seems like the definition of
nothing
so can you so on your view then what is
going on both with black holes and also
at the Big Bang
well first of all I don't think there
was a big bang I don't think you can
create it and this can be resolved
easily with just definition we do not
need to carry out any tests we do not go
have to travel backward in time to find
out what happened 13 billion years ago
all we have to do is Define our terms we
say that an object a thing okay is that
which has shape nothing space is that
which doesn't have shape there are
antonyms something is the opposite of
nothing something that which has shape
nothing that which doesn't have shape
with those two definitions we can easily
uh show that you cannot convert
something into nothing and you cannot
morph nothing into something so matter
has always been there there has there
was no moment of creation there was no
Singularity that started it all with or
without God because even if we put God
you would have to explain how God
created that Singularity or whatever
first piece of matter you know what what
is the mechanism and if you cannot
conceptualize the mechanism of something
arising completely out of nothing length
width and height suddenly uh
um uh spontaneously coming into being if
you cannot tell me what the process is
what the mechanism is then we don't then
it's an irrational Theory no matter how
you look at it so the first thing we
have to reject is Big Bang black hole
that's a separate issue I'm saying it's
a magnetic phenomenon and I wish I would
have known the question because uh I
have a very
um uh several videos in fact where I
illustrate what is causing that
phenomenon we call a black hole and I'll
just try to explain it here as best as
possible if you put a charge okay we'll
cut a charge in a magnetic field okay
magnetic field is coming down that
charge let's assume it's a ball ball
shaped charge will roll around in a
spiral inside that so-called magnetic
field whatever magnetic field is and I'm
saying that's what a black hole is is
that phenomena is happening uh when
people focus and see that a star is
orbiting around nothing and they say oh
there must be a very heavy mass in the
center of that Circle of that circular
motion I'm saying what's really
happening is the magnetic field of the
entire galaxy is in that region
coming down on a very I remember all the
stars are charged they are all magnetic
and so I think that what's happening is
the star is revolving around at Great
speeds around absolutely nothing because
it has this magnetic field of the entire
galaxy impinging down upon it
so that's my explanation for about the
black hole phenomenon there is no black
hole
is there but okay that's interesting
because it seems consistent with what
you've said on this slide that that you
could get mad or extremely dense just
not infinitely dense correct I mean how
much are we going to oppress this thing
and and what kind of matter is that last
bit of matter that we squash the entire
universe into the size of an atom or
smaller I mean what is that uh what kind
of matter is that
right so but I mean I mean is it I don't
I mean I'm I'm very uh ignorant of
physics but is it that I mean so you
were when you were talking about black
holes you were talking about I think the
black hole supposedly black hole
um on your view that's at the center of
the Galaxy but they're also non-galactic
black holes that aren't at the center
right there are other types of black
holes so I guess my question is could
you could you get
matter if it's so dense that it would
behave in a way that is
similar to the behavior in other words
that was the matter is so dense that
light couldn't escape is that possible
on your view no it's not possible
because uh according to my proposal
which I don't know if you can see this
you see that rope
yeah okay I'm saying light is a rope has
the shape of a robe in other words the
mediator of light is a rope it's a
torsion moving along a rope in both
directions
so a rope connects any two atoms in the
universe every atom in the universe is
connected physically connected to all
others and because of that light always
travels from one atom to the other at a
different frequency a different
wavelength but always travels from one
atom to another and with that setup it's
totally different what the
mathematicians are saying which they say
look the universe is just a bunch of
loose particles disconnected particles
individual discrete particles and these
particles are smashed together into this
thing we call a black hole and so now we
have this black hole supposedly this
object uh in the middle of nowhere
between two Galaxies for example and
it's got all this matter crushed into a
singularity whatever a singularity is
and it's just infinite density or almost
infinite density and almost uh no volume
so what they're talking about is
something they cannot see they cannot
touch meaning they'll never be able to
prove whether you're talking about they
cannot even conceptualize it because all
they're talking about is math they're
saying there's a lot of mass in a very
small area that's essentially what their
their whole Theory they're saying
there's a bunch of mass in a small area
it used to be a star now it's a little
uh Singularity which we'll call a black
hole and anything it gets close to it it
gets sucked in but they cannot tell you
what the mechanism is for example if I
have a singularity and I have its Event
Horizon which is what a black hole is a
singularity with its uh globular you
know it's a spherical Event Horizon okay
so let's concede the Assumption let's
say that there is such an object in the
universe now we're going to have another
star which is outside uh or close to
that that black hole we have this star
there how by what mechanism physical
mechanism does the star pull matter or
the entire star into the black hole by
what I mean does it throw a lasso uh
what's the physical mechanism and they
will not give you a physical mechanism
they'll just see the mass is so great
that it attracts it but see mass is is a
mathematical concept they haven't given
me a mechanism of how the black hole
attracted the star if I want to attract
a donkey I put a rope around the snag
and pull that in we all understand that
but if you say look my mass attracts the
the donkey and you say well by what
mechanism and we call that black magic
that's what it is black magic
masted it
Okay so
[Laughter]
where does that leave gravity
well gravity again you can conceptualize
it if every atom in the universe is I
don't know can you see my two fists here
I don't know
okay yeah my two fists are my our two
atoms okay and they're connected by a
rope
physical Road this is a physical this is
not energy this is not field this is not
wave this is a rope okay a two a two a
pair of
um uh uh Point strands okay so if
everything in the universe is physically
interconnected if every atom is
physically connected to every other atom
now we can begin to understand action at
a distance because there is no real
action at a distance the reason the
Milky Way pulls on the Andromeda Galaxy
is because you know these two things
every atom in one Galaxy is connected
physically connected to every atom in
the other Galaxy
so now we can start you know to
understand action at a distance gravity
uh so I mean yeah that seems like a
radically oh yeah I mean so yeah
a sociological question I guess I mean
so
are you a lone voice crying out in the
wilderness or are there others who well
yeah we're uh 10 10 uh crazy guys
essentially you know I came up with this
uh theory in 1998 and since then there
are some people who subscribe to it they
like it they try they are researching it
but obviously this is not this has not
hit the mainstream even though I
published a couple papers uh on the
subject it's uh it's one of those where
it never got any highlighted in anywhere
yeah and so you know this is the status
quo uh after 20 years uh you know it's
not out there it's just for those people
who are lucky enough to come to my site
hear it and at least they get another
vision of the universe whether they
believe it or not it's not a question of
belief it's a question of understanding
it's a question of look we're proposing
something different and you look at it
and you understand it and then you reach
your own conclusion that's the way we
look at it
um earlier you said that we were talking
about the direction of time and you
talked about that that is uh nonsense
the time doesn't have a direction yeah
um
and so I guess one thought that I had
about that is that would imply that any
question about
related to that so I take it like my
understanding of physics is that it is
an open question and that physicists
treat it as an open question why is it
that time goes in One Direction and not
the other and you're saying that's just
a completely misconceived that's not
even a real question
let me tell you why or one of the
underlying problems with that no one in
the last three thousand years after you
find a word time no one can tell you
what time is some people say it's what a
time what a clock measures uh they have
all different different uh uh Notions of
what time is nobody bothers defining it
they just say look uh let's deal with
the seconds with the minutes with the
years and uh let me tell you that if one
twin travels faster than the other well
he'll have a different age and then his
brother and stuff like that in others
they reach conclusion they never Define
the word time and and so what I had to
do was Define the word time even though
we do not use it the word time in
physics uh they use it in mathematic
goal physic 9 in physics physics we have
no use for time but I had to Define what
these people were referring to and I'm
saying time is a comparison of two
motions you need memory in order to have
time without memory you cannot have time
so any animal for example a lion that
has memory they have a conception of
time a rudimentary conception of time
and again all you need is two motions
once you compare one motion against
another motion you have time and so once
you have that then it's meaningless to
talk about direction or to even use uh
numerical time to uh to do anything
other than describe the motion of
something we have no use to I I cannot
use time to explain anything any
mechanism in the universe
Bill let me interject I have an
interesting question all right so
there's people who say like you know
he'd say like if I were to give you a
chocolate bar after an infinite amount
of time would you ever get the chocolate
bar obviously not so they'll say that
like the unit the universe like if you
have eternal matter it couldn't have
existed for an infinite amount of time
like if you say if you say it always
existed
that that would be implying that it
would it would have existed for an
infinite amount of time which is
nonsensical if there had to be a point
in time where it was created and and so
like I want to know like what you would
think about this and I think I have I
have a suggestion to help solve this
Paradox and you can tell me if it's
valid or not
um like when we say that and like let's
just say there was an object whether
it's a God or a leprechaun or or like an
asteroid if it existed it was eternally
existent it it it it never uh was
created it was always there when you say
something was always there that's not
akin to saying it existed for an
infinite amount of ticks on a clock it's
like you know and it's just like and if
you know I think you say that you know
things were always moving there was
never a time when something was
stationary and then move things were
always moving well is that saying that
if you're saying things are always
moving aren't you implying that things
were moving for an infinite amount of
time no it's not the same thing and like
I kind of have like a suggestion like at
every point point in the Universal frame
in the Universal movie when you have an
object moving even in a single point of
reference gravity is is pulling on it
there's something active going on even
in one frame of the universal movie even
if you don't get to the other thing
gravity is always pulling on it so
there's always something going on even
in a single frame so that's how you can
have an object always moving yet that
doesn't mean that you're implying that
it's moving for an infinite amount of
time what would you have to say about
that okay uh I'm gonna correct you on
the two two things there the first one
is this last thing that you said you
cannot have Motion in a single frame of
the universal movie because you're
talking about to put in these terms a
cross-section of time cross-sectional
time means that all you have is location
location is a static concept all you
have is distance between objects it's
like if Mother Nature or father Universe
suddenly chopped the time and everything
just stands still you know like in the I
think uh there was a Twilight Zone
version of that where everything just
stands still and that's how you have to
conceptualize it's not even an electron
is moving within a photograph okay the
photograph is a single frame in the
movie uh if you look at that frame
there's nothing moving in there
conceptually there's nothing moving and
so uh no you don't you do not have
gravity in the sense of motion you have
gravity in what I explained as weight
weight is a static concept weight is
location specific you have weight for a
given location with respect to the Earth
so if we were to freeze the astronaut
falling to earth right let's say we
freeze the image
he has a certain weight there he still
has okay yeah no no if if we freeze the
frame uh say a minute later so we have
two frames one frame one minute earlier
one frame a minute later that astronaut
is gonna weigh differently with respect
to the Earth why what's happened is the
number of ropes that from every one of
his atoms of his body right every atom
in his body is connected to every atom
of the earth that's the Assumption as he
approaches the Earth the ropes
um fan out when they fan out those that
were on the same axis are no longer on
the same axis you have more what I call
effective ropes so in a sense you're
right in a sense you're wrong there is
no motion but you would have for example
different weights okay the number of
robes in a single picture that you would
get in the Universal movie
okay now let me get you to the other
question the other issue is your word
infinite infinite is an irrational term
it should never be used on planet Earth
okay yeah look at the level end of the
Clinger infinite is an adjective
adjectives can in physics not in
ordinary speech okay or in mathematical
physics
yeah in in science in physics you can
only use adjectives to qualify objects
you cannot say infinite motion infinite
time that's an irrational statement in
physics
uh objects are finite all objects are
fine they have a shape therefore they
they're all finite in that sense an
infinite object is an irrational term
because you've defined objects that
which is fine now you're saying an
infinite finite you see what I'm saying
if it's infinite that means you cannot
see its shape yeah and if you can
actually get shape then you cannot even
talk about an object you got to show the
shape of an object in order to talk
about an object so I just want to
clarify that on the infinite now uh the
basic question was what uh as you
started out your your your talk there
what was that yeah so the question is if
an object always existed okay okay
uh let me blow your mind out and and for
this you're going to need a beer okay to
listen to this okay I want you to get up
here real quick from your Bridge because
you're really gonna need it close enough
got some buy there was never a first
human in the universe
let me repeat that there was never a
first you a human in the universe what
do I mean by that I'm saying if we go a
million years two million years to
another side of the universe we would
probably find humans developed in that
planet
okay uh we can conceive this it's very
likely that we're not the only life in
the universe we're probably not the only
humans in the universe okay somewhere
maybe the conditions were ripe for there
to be a planet like the Earth where
humans eventually evolved for in that
planet okay a million years before that
some other place in the universe there
must have been another planet like that
one like the Earth where humans develop
a million years before that some other
place in the universe and so on down the
line all the way to Nowhere the notion
that there's a beginning to things is a
very human
um you know notion uh widespread notion
babies are born we say well this is what
he was born this is when he came into
existence he was created he was born the
universe was not born you know father
universe is eternal in that sense it's
very hard for us to conceptualize that
because we say what do you mean it
existed forever who made it you know
nobody made it no it just there it's uh
all matter has been there because matter
cannot convert into space and space
cannot convert into matter so so and and
because space is that which has no shape
matter has no place to go it cannot
cross a line that says oh I'm going to
lean space it can't because space is not
a container space is not Infinite Space
is nothing which means that which has no
shape not even God can escape space
because he's got nobody in the state
yeah he has no boundary to cross and so
yeah it's very hard for us to understand
uh Eternal uh forever
uh but again time is a notion that we've
invented uh father universe doesn't
understand time
okay get it now yeah go ahead Jason when
you talk about
human beings living on other planets
like
I I think there's a way of taking that
which maybe you don't intend okay but I
want to clarify you don't mean
that there are Homo sapiens living on
other planets you mean that there are
other intelligent creatures that we
would call persons but they're not in
the biological sense of human being we
mean a descendant of other human beings
and that species evolved on Earth and
it's very unlikely and I guess even
biologically impossible for the same
species to evolve with a different
evolutionary history and so what you
would get on what you would have on
other planets aren't beings that have
our evolutionary history no matter how
much they're like us and since they
don't share our evolutionary history
they're not human beings
I don't I so I I just want to clarify
you you weren't saying that there would
be literal Homo sapiens on other planets
I have a theory and I've got it in
writing if intelligence like ours arose
on another planet those people look
exactly like us there can be no other
form for intelligence the maximum
intelligence the universe can create
except us the planet has to have certain
parameters it would have to be a certain
distance from its star it would have to
have a certain size certain gravity a
certain tilt a certain magnetism right
and once it has all these things it's
inevitable the way I look at it for that
plan to evolve if it's going to evolve
intelligence like ours like if we could
go to that planet we would see people
like us it can't be any other way that's
my theory could they have pointy ears
uh there could be different
characteristics but in general they
would look more or less like us
interesting and I
I would have to see there's more this
this
an hour another hour at least but all
I'm saying is I'm just giving you my
point of view my point of view is that
anywhere in the universe where
intelligence of our level arose the
humans over there look more or less like
us okay you know
yeah
I also also had a question about
infinity and you were making the point I
took I take you to have been making the
point that there's nothing like Infinity
doesn't apply to physical objects but
what about mathematical things are there
you know there are mathematicians who
don't think
that Infinity is a concept that should
be used in pure mathematics so in other
words and so they don't they would not
they would reject the idea that there
are an infinite number of natural
numbers
um yeah yeah because the question I mean
some people like Cantor George or Cantor
and um uh there was another German guy
escaped my mind right now uh and they
they did a lot of studies on Infinities
and it's all numbers in the end it's you
know it's um
what are we talking about when we're
saying infinite are we talking about
counting infinitely are we talking about
dividing between two numbers infinitely
you know what do we mean and you know if
you go all the way to Aristotle they
talked about you know Infinity it was
something that really concerned them
like you know how many points are
between two points you know between two
numbers and they figured out that you
could put as many numbers as you want as
long as you keep adding more and more
decimals yeah it's like the Grim Reaper
Reaper Paradox kind of yeah yeah
it's it's like the hotel what is it the
Middleburg hotel that's another guy I
was thinking of Hilbert uh you know he
talked about uh Infinities as well all
these people just are mathematicians who
like to play around with numbers and
what they they did they they're talking
about Concepts you know Concepts yeah
dreams we we can have a million of those
you know infinite ones if you want if
you want to use the word but when you're
talking about physics the word infinity
has no place in it because first there
are not infinite objects there are not
infinite sized uh or infinite in other
words an object cannot be infinite you
cannot have infinite number of objects
and the space is not infinite because
space is not a thing space is nothing
that space is that which does not have
shave therefore you cannot talk about
the Infinity of space you can talk about
the Infinity of a horse which would make
no sense because all courses are finite
and so on
their language correctly in other words
are there such things as moments but
there are definitely say things as
minutes right well not things well what
do you mean
there's I mean like I can so there are
instances
concept there are certainly instances of
counting right where where I'm counting
from one to sixty
now I don't think that
so
take that that is an interval of time
right
like the time it takes me from to count
from 1 to 60
call that a minute
are is it if if there's no beginning of
the universe isn't that equivalent to
saying that there are an infinite number
of minutes yeah that's what I was
getting at yeah like because it's like
remember Bill how you're talking about I
go a million years before there's humans
go a million years but like it seems
like you're replying like an infinite or
incessant regress so there would always
be that but it's like yeah isn't that
saying that there was no big I mean is
it didn't it there have to be a
beginning to everything
humans and millions of years later see
like it started
let me give you a couple answers to your
to both of your concerns the first one
is the fine I'm saying that this is the
entire universe okay it's uh I hope you
can see that yeah okay it's a closed
loop thread that's all there is in the
universe closely thread you can say in
space within space even though the space
is not a container okay it says but this
is all there is just floating out there
yeah this this single thread converts
into the ropes that
um uh bind any two atoms and the atoms
themselves are made of the same thread
so it's all a single thread the whole
thing now and they're saying you're
saying the ropes
eternally they were always there never
created and let me let me show you this
uh I give you this okay uh uh Ed and you
start here you start here and you you
begin going all around every atom in the
universe through every road through
every thread and you're going to come
back to here yeah
uh if you look at the whole thing it's
just a single object it's just a single
thread closed blue thread and so there
is no Infinity in in the sense of the
there's only one object the infinity is
in your mind who is doing the running
around the measuring or the experiencing
by going from one end to the other but
the universe is laughing at you because
saying all he did was go around the
thread that's existing in in uh in in
the present tense so to speak
mm-hmm you see what I'm saying that
there's only a single object which is
this thread and it's there it's like
it's almost present it's always in
present mode in that sense it's always
infinite in time or Eternal in time okay
yeah and it's a single thread it's it's
like you know I I can have a a ball in
the middle of space that as as long as
no one touches it maybe that ball stays
there forever and you say well how much
time has gone by well the ball doesn't
know the ball says I'm always in the
present
yeah see that's the thing because I was
like okay I understand like okay yeah so
you're saying the ropes were eternally
existent matters Eternal okay I got that
so it's like that's a the thing that
people have their their have a hard time
wrapping their mind around so you're
saying okay the thread all the threads
were always there okay so isn't that
saying they were there for an infinite
amount it was there for an infinite
amount of time and you're saying no
no it's the president yeah
maybe you put it in a different way
suppose I think about what I call the
future okay and I'm and and suppose I
take a magic potion and I become
immortal
contrary to fact and
I just keep going a little lizard hat uh
what would I experience a million my by
my counting a million 10 million a
billion years 10 billion years what
would that what would I see all you
would do all you would be doing is again
uh you know those little drawings where
they have a little man made out of uh
it's a stick man you know it's and he's
made out of one line only and the line
then goes around turns into some kind of
circle or whatever and so the the little
man this this uh stick man is the same
thing as a little circle he's going
around in and so he's losing his leg but
creating a new leg forward because it's
the same thread so to speak and that's
what you would be doing if you're here's
you going around you know the thread
you're made out of threads okay every
atom in your body is made out of threads
you would be rolling around the universe
eternally I guess and going from one end
of the universe to the other and the
threat is you yourself
so the threat is is is taking a shave
from one region of the thread to another
that's all you're doing as an infinite
human being
so I guess part of what I'm thinking is
that the the circle metaphor makes me
think about
eternal recurrence
and I'm wondering I I what you just said
makes me think that's not what you meant
you don't need it okay I'm saying I'm
saying that we that the thread is always
in the present and as far as the threat
is going to turn this Home Father
Universe like I like to call this thread
the thread is in in the present always
in the presence different parts of its
body you know the atoms over there the
Galaxy over there the star in the other
direction all those are part of this
single thread that uh is in space that's
floating out there in space and it
itself the universe itself is always in
the present tense it doesn't know it
itself father Universe himself he
doesn't know what the past is or what
the future is he's always in the present
in that sense he's Eternal okay Bill all
right so I think we're getting into the
heart of the matter here let me give you
a question that will make it even uh
easier uh to understand because I know
this is like a complicated issue okay so
I can understand the ropes eternally
existing okay
was there ever a point when the ropes
went from non-motion to motion or as
motion oh so Eternal the motion I
believe is eternal any any
like we cannot conceptualize nothing
becoming something in the same way we
cannot conceptualize the beginning of
motion why would why would something
that is inanimate right let's let's
remove God for a second right okay
something that is inanimate like this
thread if it's standing still one part
with respect to the other floating in
the universe what would get one part of
this thread to move for the first time
you would need some kind of external
input
you know and we're discounting that like
what moved it yeah so yeah so so we have
this issue with with God that people
analyze in the past you know which is is
he the prime mover is God the prime
mover and and so people say well who
Moved God yeah I mean we get to this
recursive thing where you know you say
well who Moved God and how did God come
into being well he had a mother I don't
know you know or they say he's Eternal
so you end up with eternity no matter
what yeah so but but like uh so you're
saying okay so you have non-motion then
you have motion how do we get from there
um wouldn't it be like wouldn't it be
the pull of the ropes like here it's
like in frame one you have non-motion
because the Rope is pulling but it has
yet to pull up to the second frame and
then and then finally when the pooling
has fully commenced now we have the
second frame of the universal movie
movie where you have a one location of
an object and outside a different
location so wouldn't it be the pool of
the ropes that makes it go from when you
say pool you're already using a verb
you're saying okay what caused the pole
I mean
what about the torsion and the weights
no the same thing you cannot you cannot
conceptualize the origin of motion you
simply cannot okay I see what you're
saying okay so then okay so motion
always motion like existence is eternal
so it's like okay mostly I think it's a
little more problem with emotion because
you're saying motion is eternal there's
always been motion yeah and then someone
says so are you saying that the ropes
moved an infinite amount of locations
you would say no so then but then like
okay you're saying no to that but then
it's like how was that true if there's
always motion because you think motion
you're like you know one two three four
five six
and you know like how would you explain
that that it's not infinite motion yet
there's always been motion
again let's get rid of the word infinite
that word is dangerous okay if it is the
wrong word we're talking about eternal
you can use eternal you can say constant
stuff like that which are adverbs in the
context of physics okay so so you have
this uh thread okay out there
it's always been there it's always in
the present tense as far as it's
concerned but there is motion between in
different parts of the thread because
this red forms atoms over there atoms
over there and atoms in the other place
and these atoms turn into Stars they
turn into galaxies Etc so you have these
galaxies in throughout the the universe
okay they're all in motion you cannot
conceptualize one of these beginning to
move for the first time or even I cannot
even conceptualize uh the thread be an
untied completely so that you get this
and vice versa I cannot conceptualize
this converting into that in other words
I don't think the universe at some point
disentangled itself completely and
formed a uh close-up thread and then
came back you know some some something
like an oscillating Universe where it
turns into the thread and the thread
turns into all the matter in the
universe I don't think that ever
happened I think it's always been like
what we see out there the today we see
the same thing that if you came back a
gazillion years ago or come in the
future a gazillion years in the future
you would see the same universe
essentially the Stars might change maybe
this star is over here in someplace else
with respect to other stars because
again the relation is always with
respect to the rest of the matter in the
universe but you would not see you would
not see at any point in time the start
of the universe or the stop of the of
motion oh yeah okay so okay so you're
saying okay motion's Eternal so that
means that the pool of the ropes is a
term
the ropes don't pull I want to make sure
we always clarify that uh in in
mathematical physics uh they have pull
push and they have four forces right
they have pull push maybe and perhaps
the four forces of quantum mechanics
because if you take the glue on the the
strong force and you take the uh weak
Force you know weak force is a push
force and uh gluon or the strong force
is a pull Force so we still have two
poles and two pushes no one invented
anything other than pull and push but I
invented a third push a third uh Force
okay which is not a force at all it's
called tension
the Rope is always under tension it
doesn't pull it doesn't push it always
it always maintains the same tension
between two atoms and that tension is
regulated by the velocity of light which
is
now what I'm saying is the tension is
the 300 000 kilometers per second which
is a speed of light is a measure of the
tension on the Rope all you can do with
a rope is change the number of links and
make them smaller or un you know unwind
them and make the links longer okay okay
frequency times wavelength is the
velocity of light and it's a constant
and if you torque the Rope more you
still have frequency times wavelength
the frequency has increased the number
of links the length length has decreased
so for a given length of rope you know
you're going to have fewer links and
each link and each link is going to be
longer and vice versa if uh if you
tighten the Rope you know each link is
going to become smaller and you're going
to have more links that's frequency
times wavelength right there okay so but
is the tension motion no no but this is
what I'm saying okay let me get back to
tension so tension means the following
means no one wins the tug of war
in the case of the word Force means that
someone wins a tug of wars of War uh uh
if you push means that you move
something in some direction if you pull
you move something in some Direction
when you're under tension it's like if
you have I'll take my magic wand here
okay it's like if you have a stick
you have to think of it like that like a
solid stake uh that doesn't change
that's tension there is no one winning
the tug of war and I'm saying that the
Rope is always under tension so the Rope
doesn't pull
it's the atoms that might move in One
Direction or another but but the atoms
the atoms also because they're made out
of the Rope the atoms slide along the
Rope
okay so it I'm trying to see it does
this the atom moves through the Rope
because it's made out of the Rope so it
slides like a beat on an abacus also the
tension always Remains the Same between
any two atoms on the road and that's why
Einstein could not explain why you do
not add the speed of light to the
flashlight that you turned on on the
train why don't you add the speed of the
train to the speed of light because the
atoms are going right through the Rope
they're sliding through the Rope that's
why you do not have to add the speed of
the train uh to the speed of light okay
that's actually okay I'm kind of I'm
understanding things a little better um
I mean you know this is something that
it takes a whole day to explain about
every piece of it I'm just giving you
snapshots I know because yeah because
like the question is like Suppose there
was something like God or even something
that you know existed and it operated on
natural laws I guess it would just have
to be able to withstand the negative 32
degrees Fahrenheit and that was an
eternal being in that Consciousness like
what would the experience be like always
existing it's always hard to imagine
that because it's like you know no one
has had that experience before but we've
done about our best wrap our minds
around like you know that Paradox so
thanks for giving that bill and and
thanks Jason for you know asking some
good questions all right I got to close
it off go ahead
um since you you know you brought up
Einstein and he's come up in the past
um what what are the implications of
your view for things like time dilation
um well I explained that very well and
and let me just give you a quick answer
to that uh we have uh two twins for
example the famous twin paradox I guess
you heard about that one twin goes out
and goes around a black hole comes back
he finds his brother is 40 30 40 years
older than him depending on how fast he
traveled Etc
we got a problem and this is very easily
solved okay very easily solved in this
uh fences with time dilation altogether
in that context and that and this is the
following how many times uh did the
earth go around the Sun Well when around
the Sun 20 years uh 20 times so that's
20 years because the definition of the
word year is the orbit of the Earth
around the Sun that's how you know we
don't count the candles on your birthday
cake with a with a atomic clock we count
them by the number of years which means
a number of times the Earth went around
the Sun so if the twin went out to the
black hole and came back
how many times when uh how many years
have gone by well the number of years is
always determined by the earth going
around the Sun and if the Earth went
around us on 20 years that's how many
years went by and we don't care what his
atomic clock says you know we count the
number of years according to the Earth
and so when this guy comes back they say
first that 40 years have gone by maybe
for the uh when that stayed at home in
only two years for the guy who traveled
that's wrong if it was 40 years that's
40 years and the guy was just two years
is wrong period and now the other issue
is whether the guy aged he became older
younger younger by traveling or stayed
young while the other guy you know
became older well I like to use a real
nasty trick there and I say what if the
guy who traveled suddenly caught
Progeria as soon as he left the Earth
you know he's gonna die probably to come
back dead because he aged very fast
which has absolutely nothing to do with
time but has to do with you know other
factors uh biological factors so we
cannot say how old the guy's gonna be uh
if he comes back I mean in terms of
biological time and if we want to know
how much time went by we just have the
number of uh Earth orbits and we're done
that's how we do so like for one guy if
it if it's like if he came back and that
took 20
um circular movements of the Earth
around the Sun than for the other guy
it's also going to be 20s it's not going
to be like 2080. yeah that's a good yeah
I don't care
but might say two years I don't care
that that's his clock here he's got to
get through it
so yeah okay so right so he's his clock
says he only took him two years yeah and
the intuition is that his body is only
going to have aged as if it was only two
years yeah but again if he caught
Progeria he might be older than his
brother
so that's a biological issue true but
then and then there's the issue of the
experience of it and again the intuition
is he will have experienced it as only
two years not as 20 years whereas his
brother would have experienced it as 20
years well for that we have
psychologists laughs
that's there you go
I'm already yeah okay all right bill I
think we should close off I want to talk
just a little bit about um flatter
videos because I know you recently you
talk against uh people who believe that
the Earth is flat and they give like
varying evidences and stuff so why don't
you give us some of the best evidences
they have and like debunk it or debunk
their misunderstandings yeah well the
the for me it's just outrageous that in
this day and age we have people who
believe in in the Flat Earth the problem
with the Flat Earth on the one hand uh
they they criticize The Establishment
they don't believe a lot of stuff of the
establishment and a lot of them are
simply people who are into politics
they're into
um uh you know um uh conspiracies okay a
lot of them are are heavily into that
nothing wrong with that but keep it
within politics don't bring it into
science that's one issue but then what's
the issue they they try to explain
gravity and you have these different
explanations which really have a very
little mechanistic uh explanations what
they have is simply saying you know it's
more density it's density you know this
is how they would explain gravity or
another guy says well it's not that uh
the astronaut Falls to Earth but that
the Earth comes up against the astronaut
and and on and on and on and I asked
only one questions of the uh flat
earthers and I say how flat is flat
that's the question how flat is flat I
mean flat is too too deep that's flat
and if it's more than uh 2D what are you
talking about a pancake maybe that's got
3D that's that's not flat so what do you
mean by flat and no one ever defined the
word flat they just talk about the Flat
Earth but they never say how flat it is
because they've never defined a word
flat and that's why I Define the word
flat I say it's uh flat is 2D that's
what flat is and if they don't like it
well all they have to do is give me a
better definition you know a better
mousetrap so obviously we're on
something 3D so it's like yeah and it
would have to be like the pancake I
guess they mean it's less Global and
like closer to that of a pancake like
it's not you know completely flat but
it's closer to that than like the big
glow now yeah but again uh there's a lot
of stuff they cannot explain uh in a
rational way okay they explained it in
their minds but they don't explain it in
a rational way one of the issues that I
do attack is uh their argument that you
cannot curve water
uh you know in a um in in a globular
Earth they say look water always stays
flat when I put water in my bathtub it's
always flat and the rubber duct is
floating on a flat you know surface
right okay this is their argument they
say so how can you curve water you know
how do you how do you get the oceans to
curve assuming there's a globe right and
uh yeah with a rope model no problem
because every atom of the water every
atom of the air is connected to the
Center of the Earth so you know if if
you look at that that gives you a a
spherical uh object essentially and so
water is curved very easily under my
under the Rope model but uh but in in
their case they say look it's got to be
flat and I'm saying no it doesn't have
to be flat because you know they're
looking at a small surface all the time
they're they're not looking at a you
know like from Outer Space if you look
at the Earth well you know then you can
see this curve but they say well we
never went into space and they get into
the conspiracy mode at that point and so
it's very hard to argue
okay all right yeah that's interesting
all right I guess uh before we tune out
I'll just let Jason come in with some
final comments and I'll just give you
know closing statements oh I I don't I
was gonna just say that I don't I I've
heard this water can't be curved line
before I just don't even understand it
uh but I mean yeah I mean there's
the the uh the shape that the Earth
casts on the moon during the eclipse is
another extremely good piece the only
thing that would cast a consistently
circular [ __ ] uh Shadow is a sphere
um I don't know how you get a pancake to
always cast a circular product anyway
um but yeah I Bill thank you for coming
I really enjoyed hearing your views and
exploring that with you
um I'm not sure that I understand
everything as you say this is a
introduction someone does the first
thing yeah believe me but I appreciate
your handling all of the questions I
threw at you
um and uh you know doing it uh in good
humor and I think you answered
everything thoroughly I mean I still
have lots of questions but obviously
next time yeah yeah yeah I know that's
that's not something
yeah he's thinking to like semantics
because I think there's like an issue of
miscommunication because like Bill will
say like you know jumping doesn't exist
and people will think like oh he's
saying jumping doesn't exist he's
implying semantically that jumping
doesn't happen but that's not what he's
saying he's saying jumping happens you
see we can see it but that is not the
same as saying it exists in a scientific
context because existence I mean you can
only in order to use a term valid you'd
have to be consistently used so if
you're going to Define existence as you
know that which is three-dimensional or
that which has is three-dimensional and
has location you can also say that it's
an event so like the best way to say it
is that jumping really happens but
that's a description of existence
jumping is not existence itself it's a
description of existence it's all about
proper semantics you know so and like
that takes a long time for people to
like understand because they got to take
out their like the ordinary definitions
they've been used to make associations
with and that takes a long time and then
they can kind of understand what Bill's
getting at you know like you know like
people will sometimes use like
Dimensions coordinated vectors like you
know synonymously like Hawkins said like
hey the plane's a certain height above
sea level but but you know Heights what
a an object has you know it's a certain
it's like that so yeah I think you know
it's interesting and it gives you it
makes you see like the world and the the
way it should be seen you know
Yeah well yeah I mean um like I said I
don't I can't claim to believe it
because I don't understand all of it and
it is contrary to to stuff that I've
learned
um
there's that issue too but nonetheless I
did find it very interesting and uh and
I really appreciate your coming here and
telling you got to come to our
conference the next time well an excuse
to go to Germany sounds like I know I
think they're thinking about doing it in
Austria in Salisbury either way yeah
yeah all righty well thank you all very
much for tuning in and in a couple of
minutes I'll have this link and I'll
send it to you to both to share around
and you can share this on your rational
science Facebook page Bill sure a lot of
people there's a lot on here we cover a
bunch of diverse topics so it's like an
all-in-one bundle so I'm sure your views
were your viewers will appreciate this
one alrighty guys thanks a lot and you
all have a good day bye-bye